from mistress to Monarch who is King
Charles's wife Camilla
Charles metcamila on Windsor Great Park
Polo Field in 1970 she was back from
finishing schools in Switzerland and
France he had just left Cambridge
University and was about to join the
Navy
they became close but the relationship
cooled when the prince went to sea in
1973.
Camilla Shand married army officer
Andrew Parker Bowles on July the 4th
1973. they had two children Tom Parker
Bowles and Laura Lopez but before that
Andrew had been romantically linked to
Camilla's now sister-in-law Princess
Anne the pair dated for some time in
1970 sharing a love of horses but it
wasn't meant to be
eight years after the Parker balls
wedding Charles married Diana it's
thought Charles resumed his romance with
Camilla at some point in the 80s
in 1992 Charles and Diana formally
separated
just three months later a private
conversation between Charles and Camilla
in 1989 was leaked to the press the
explicit six-minute phone call caused a
scandal when details of it were printed
it's now often referred to as tampon
gate
in 1994 Charles admitted he'd been
unfaithful to Diana once the marriage
had irretrievably broken down in an
interview with David dimbleby then in
1995 during a now controversial BBC
Panorama interview Diana famously said
there were three people in her marriage
referring to Camilla after the interview
the queen wrote to Charles saying a
divorce between him and Diana was
desirable that same year Camilla and
Andrew Parker Bowles announced their
divorce and in 1996 Charles and Diana
finalized theirs a year later Diana was
tragically killed in a car crash
after the death of Diana Charles and
Camilla worked hard to rehabilitate
Camilla's Public Image
they were photographed together for the
first time as a couple at the Ritz in
London attending the birthday party of
Camilla's sister Annabelle Elliott in
1999. a year later the queen who
reportedly had previously refused to
acknowledge Camilla met her for the
first time Camilla and Charles married
in 2005. the queen didn't attend the
Civil ceremony because she was the head
of the Church of England which then
disapproved of divorce and remarriage
but she wasn't the blessing ceremony
which was held at St George's Chapel in
Windsor in his Memoir spare Prince Harry
revealed he and his brother William had
begged Charles not to marry Camilla
Camilla was initially cast as the
villain in the story of Charles and
Diana barter she carved out her own
Royal role the mood towards her has
softened
during the Platinum Jubilee Queen
Elizabeth II stated it was her sincere
wish that Camilla be named Queen consort
when Charles takes the throne the last
queen consort in Britain was Queen
Elizabeth the queen mother who was given
the title when she married George VI
after the coronation of King Charles
Camilla will be crowned by his side as
Queen